All cancers are caused by changes in the DNA of cells.
DNA carries the cells' genetic information.
And that information changes when some cells gradually mutate,...
...from normal to abnormal, and then to malignant, over time.
Scientists say if they could only crack the genetic codes of different types of cancers,...
...they could save millions of lives.
Blood tests could spot tumors early on.
And treatment would be far more successful.
Dr. Jeanny Aragon-Ching is an oncologist at the George Washington University Medical Center.
She says this discovery is a step toward an era of personalized medicine.
That is the thrust now because,...
...for instance, for cancers, specific types of cancers,...
...we have different drugs that target specific domains or mutations.
The more information doctors have about how cancer cells develop,...
...the more precisely they can prescribe a treatment to target those particular cells.
British scientists found 30,000 mutations in melanoma,...
...a type of skin cancer that accounts for 75% of skin cancer deaths.
They also found 23,000 mutations in small-cell lung cancer.
But not all of these mutations cause cancer.
It is the role of physicians and scientists...
...to find out which of those mutations are the driving force,...
...or the driving mutation that actually led to the cancer.
Eventually, scientists might be able to target precancerous cells...
...and prevent deadly tumors from forming.
But that day is still far away.
As an oncologist,...
...my goal would be to one day see that we can transform cancer into a chronic disease.
Okay, certainly cure but cure is probably too generous of a word the way I see it,...
...but to convert it to something more like chronic disease that can be treatable.